hey guys it's Jan here as the second
installment in the DC extended universe
Batman V Superman dawn of Justice firmly
establishes Superman Batman and Wonder
Woman and sets up numerous future movies
like Suicide Squad and Justice League
the film is stacked with all mergers and
hidden references to the many Batman and
Superman films before it as well as the
comic books so I put together all the
Easter eggs and references I could find
in this video of course I'd love to hear
about any others you spot it too just
before that I've got an awesome giveaway
thanks to our friends at Titan Books so
if you'd like the chance to win this
fantastic hardback book Batman V
Superman dawn of Justice the art of the
film which is packed with stunning
concept art storyboards blueprints
costume detail and behind-the-scenes
shots from the set then make sure you
subscribe and leave a comment about your
favorite Easter Egg for the movie on
this video for more details and ways to
enter check out the gleam link in the
video description below and a quick
warning there will be spoilers ahead so
if you haven't seen the movie yet check
out my non-spoiler review here the Dark
Knight Returns by Frank Miller was a
major influence on Batman V Superman and
when Batman jumps on the side of a
building during the showdown with
doomsday it's a visual homage to the
cover of the comic book series
Doomsday's look his bony protrusions and
claw-like armor similar to his look in
the death of Superman by Dan Jurgens
and Superman's final moments with Lois
Lane his pivotal battle and death at the
hands of the super villain are also
references to this seminal comic book
the coffin for Superman state burial
recalls a similar one used when Superman
died battling doomsday in the animated
movie Superman doomsday in which
Superman comes back from the dead and
during the final scene at the Kent
family burial grounds you can hear a few
light thumps in the music that resemble
a heartbeat a hint that Superman will be
coming back to life and likely a nod to
the way Batman faked his death in The
Dark Knight Returns by slowing his
heartbeat and the earth which starts to
move and float up in the very final shot
recalls the way the earth moved around
Superman's fists when he first learned
how to fly in Man of Steel the movie
introduces Wonder Woman and XI sports a
number of her classic tools and weapons
from the comics including her tiara belt
bulletproof bracelets and lasso of truth
and her shield might also be in
to the Amazonian magic sphere from the
comics which had mystical properties as
Diana Prince she also was a range of
gold jewelry which are nods to her
Wonder Woman logo in accessories and at
Lex Luthor's party when Bruce Wayne
chases after Diana Prince who's stolen
his hacking device he has to avoid a
cake or model of a Greek temple being
taken out to the party which is a visual
reference to when the woman's Amazonian
background from Greek mythology Lex
Luthor starts the film with a full head
of her but when his head is shaven in
prison he ends up with his more common
board look from the comics and if you
look closely at the prison guards on
either side of him you'll see they have
Belle Reve badges on their uniforms
which means he's likely going to come
into contact with the Suicide Squad and
Lex Luthor's prisoner number 16 tk-421
is an easter egg to the stormtrooper
tk-421 he was ambushed by Han Solo in
Star Wars a new home Martha Kent works
as a waitress at rally's diner and not
to the Superman comics were lets loose
her visits of Raleigh's diner and makes
a fake proposal to a waitress to give
her a million dollars if she spends a
month with him in Metropolis the Mark of
Zorro movie poster in the flashback to
the murder of Bruce Wayne's parents is
Anna Marsh the same moment in the comics
the movie Excalibur also gets a
reference which could be a nod to the
time-traveling story in the comics where
Batman and Superman travel back together
to King Arthur's Camelot later in
Bruce's dream of blood seeping out of
his parents tombs he has a vision of a
creature which looks a lot like man bat
Batman's enemy from the comics and
alphas line the next day about an empty
wine cellar and the next generation of
Wayne's
is a line of dialogue taken straight
from the Dark Knight Returns comics Oh
in the look of Batman's heavily armored
suit which he puts on to face off with
Superman is reminiscent to the same suit
that Batman used to battle Superman in
The Dark Knight Returns when Bruce Wayne
asked Clark Kent whether he owns the
Daily Planet it's a nod to the comics in
which Bruce Wayne became the owner of
The Daily Planet Perry White's line that
this isn't 1938 is a reference to the
year when Superman debuted on the cover
of Action Comics the 300 on the Russian
rocket is a nod to Frank Miller's 300
comic book series and the movie
adaptation directed by Zack Snyder
Superman getting nuked and then being
revived by the power of the Sun is a
callback to a similar moment when
Superman is struck by a missile in the
Dark Knight Returns and when Superman is
shot with Batman's kryptonite it's
another reference to Frank Miller's
comic in which Oliver Queen shoots
Superman with synthetic kryptonite that
Bruce Wayne had developed Lana Lang
Clark Kent's romantic interest in the
comics when he was growing up gets a nod
in Kevin Costner's cameo as Clark's
father and his story about accidentally
flooding the Lang's farm and of course
as the title suggests Batman V Superman
dawn of Justice sets at the DC extended
universe for the Justice League movies
and we get some big hints at the likely
Big Bad the Justice League dark side in
Batman's nightmare he looks out over a
desolate landscape or you can see dark
sides a meager symbol in the ground and
the insect-like creatures which attack
him later and most likely dark sides
parademons the soldiers dressed in black
uniforms who are working with the
parademons and kneel before Superman
suggest that we might get a corrupted
Superman in the future if he's
resurrected and also might hint that
Superman will be controlled by Darkseid
the hints at Lois's death and the
tyrannical Superman with his own
soldiers also reference the storyline in
the video game injustice gods among us
the way flash appears to Batman at the
end of his nightmare with a message Lois
is the key who calls the flashpoint
comics where Barry Allen travels to
Batman with a letter from his father
Thomas Wayne and the flash also appears
in the metahuman file which Bruce Wayne
decrypts which by the way is titled red
streak which is an easter egg to one of
the aliases for grant gustin's flash on
the CW show this also --'tis to Wonder
Woman solo movie with a photo of her in
Belgium in 1918 at the end of World War
1 alongside Chris Pines character Steve
Trevor there's also an interesting look
at the creation of cyborg who gets his
own solo movie in 2020 his father Silas
stone is working to help his wounded son
Vick at STAR Labs when a box is
activated the Box hovers over two Vic's
body and starts growing him new
cybernetic arms and legs the scene is a
nod to cyborgs origin story and the
Justice League comics were he's injured
by an exploding mother box before he's
repaired by his father to become cyborg
by the way when Lex Luthor says ding
ding ding in his cell it's a reference
to the pink sound that the mother boxes
often make in the comics according to
his video footage Aquaman appears to be
located in the Tonga train
and we not only get to see his Trident
but we also see his comic book style
SuperSpeed swimming as he zooms off at
the end of his cameo and there's another
Aquaman nod in a Daily Planet newspaper
story about water testing being put on
hold due to funding cuts which hints at
possible pollution that could affect
Aquaman as a game of Thrones Dothraki
Easter Egg to Jason mowers Khal Drogo in
the words blood of my blood which Lex
Luthor says during the creation of
doomsday and there's a King Kong star
moment when doomsday leaps to the top of
the LexCorp Tower and is then attacked
from the air by helicopters and he gives
a King Kong light roar of fury by the
way as Bruce Wayne starts decrypting the
file he recovered from Lex Corp the name
leech appears on the computer screen a
little nod to Rex Meech who appeared for
the first time in the comics during the
funeral procession of the Superman when
Dinah Prince looks at the files on the
metahumans who liz has been
investigating you can see their logos
are Persians of the official logos
released for each of the solo movies for
the new members of the Justice League
and Lex Luthor's words about Zeus
Prometheus and a thunderbolt are teased
for the superhero Shazam who is the
power of living lightning in the comic
books and he'll be getting a solo movie
in 2019 there's also stack of Easter
eggs for classic Batman villain the
Joker who will be appearing as Suicide
Squad Jack Nicholson who played the
Joker in Tim Burton's Batman movie gets
a name check in the sign for Nicholson
terminal and dock company Bruce Wayne's
line about having a bad history with
freaks dressed like clowns is also an
amusing nod to the Joker and the defaced
Robin costume hints at the Batman comic
a death in the family in which the Joker
brutally beat Jason Todd with the
crowbar and then killed him there's a
bunch more Joker Easter eggs hidden in
the graffiti in the dilapidated building
where Batman and Superman face off with
plays on the Joker's name such as Joe
and Kayla the words Joe key repeated
three times on a column and another Joe
with an arrow that points to the letters
K and R on another column and Batman
villain the Riddler gets an Easter Egg
fire a question mark graffiti Don a
column but the graffiti includes
Aphrodite the Greek goddess who appears
in the window woman comics and eNOS used
the stills photographer on Man of Steel
Batman V Superman and Wonder Woman
when Bruce Wayne clones a cellphone of
Anatole the Russian criminal working for
Lex Luthor it's a callback to Nolan's
Dark Knight movie when Lucius Fox uses a
cell phone to scan and record a map of
China
mob boss Laos building by the way
anatoly's character is based on cagey
beast from the comics and in the
blackest night Batman comic series he's
resurrected and becomes one of the Black
Lantern Corps so even though Batman
probably killed him in this movie it's
possible we could see him back in a
future film and when Bruce Wayne says to
Anatole that he knows a bit of Russian
as he spent three nights with the
Bolshoi ballerina is a callback to the
Dark Knight movie when Bruce Wayne dated
a Russian prima ballerina and went on a
cruise ship with the Russian ballet as
cover for his investigation of Lao
Jeremy Isis alfred makes fun of the
various incarnations of Batman's raspy
voice when he's playing around with
Batman's voice modulator and Alfred's
line that the white Portuguese might be
a phantasm is a little verbal shout-out
to the animated Batman film mask of the
phantasm by the way the name Penobscot
on this building in Metropolis is a
reference to the Penobscot County
Probate Court where Christopher
Richardson petitioned in 2016 to legally
change his first name to Batman Superman
nearly drowning in water with kryptonite
and being rescued by Lois Lane recalls
when he almost drowned because the
Kryptonite necklace Lex Luthor put on
him in the 1978 Superman movie and in
that movie Superman was saved by Lex
Luthor's girlfriend Bruce Wayne's
disparaging remark about the Daily
Planet publishing articles about
Superman saving cats
he's a nod to the times in the comics
and the 1978 movie when Superman rescues
a cat
Clark Kent's dog Shelby from Smallville
gets a mention in a street sign for
Shelby Street in Metropolis the
Smallville talk show good morning
metropolis also gets a shout out with
the twist when Perry White says good
morning Smallville to Clark Kent and
during the discussion between Perry
White and Clark Kent about what the
newspaper should be reporting Perry says
to Clark that the American conscience
died with Robert Martin and John a
reference to the line in Frank Miller's
The Dark Knight Returns that the
American conscience died with the
Kennedys and it's also referenced in the
1968 song Abraham Martin and John which
is a tribute to the assassinated John
and Robert Kennedy Martin Luther King
and Abraham Lincoln
Perry White also references The Wizard
of Oz when he asked where Clark Kent is
and jokes a he clicks his heels three
times and goes back to Kansas and the
Emerald City is also mentioned by Lex
Luthor when he's talking about the
Kryptonite in the Indian Ocean
actress carla Gugino returns from Man of
Steel where she voiced a Kryptonian
robot Keller
the ship's voice in BVS Gugino worked
with Zack Snyder previously playing
Madame Gorski in his movie sucker punch
and at the Daily Planet offices is a
name plaque for picture editor Liz
Ritenour who was an art department
assistant in this movie speaking a crew
named check stunt coordinator Tim Rigby
also gets a nod with the name Ric be
appearing on one of the mailboxes
belonging to Lois Lane's neighbors and
there's a cameo at the very beginning of
the movie by Jimmy Olsen he isn't named
but he's the CIA op posing as a
photographer who gets shot he's played
by actor Michael Cassidy who previously
played grant Gabriel a clone of Lex
Luthor's brother in Smallville by the
way Zack Snyder has said that he
originally wanted to cast Jesse
Eisenberg as Jimmy Olsen with the role
of Lex Luthor possibly going to Bryan
Cranston so guys what other Easter eggs
and references the new spot in Batman V
Superman and which was your favorite
don't forget to comment and subscribe
for a chance to win this official Batman
V Superman the art of the film hardback
book for more details and ways to enter
the giveaway check out the gleam link in
the video description below and if you
enjoyed this video you can check out
more of my easter egg videos for
Deadpool and daredevil season 2 here and
I've got more Batman V Superman videos
here including top WTF moments my review
and behind the scenes facts about the
movie thanks for watching and see you
next time if you got a movie lovers